trans il va se dérouler à montpellier en
l'absence quand même des chefs d'état
c'est une première esquisse vous le
trouvez quand même ambitieux emmanuel
macron le président il a toujours voulu
créer cette connexion directe entre lui
et le terrain avec les différents
acteurs c'est vraiment une approche
complètement nouvelle parce que c'est
une bonne idée aujourd'hui le sujet de
l'afrique il est tellement complexe est
tellement grand en termes de défis que
personne ne peut le résoudre tout seul
escape d'amertume quand même vis-à-vis
des initiatives qui ont été menés par
emmanuel macron aucune je pense qu'on a
été
enrichie pas naïfs c'est avec on va
changer soixante ans d'histoire en deux
jours la france a compris quand même
qu'aujourd'hui il faut repenser les
relations
ça il faut pas être un obstacle pour le
comprendre jean soûlât compris non c'est
le commun on dit secret du changement
c'est pas de de lutter contre le passé
mais ses deux pieds de mettre toutes ses
énergies dans la construction du futur
et c'est ce à quoi je vais je m'attèle
[Musique]
à la une en irak heures devrait
connaître les premiers résultats des
législatives anticipées dans les 24
heures selon la commission électorale a
le taux de participation devrait tomber
ce soir un scrutin qui a suscité peu
d'enthousiasmé chez les électeurs ellis
y allemand prévue en 2022 ces élections
elles ont été avancées pour calmer la
contestation à 2 fin 2019
huitième et dernière visite officielle
dans gala merkel en israël la
chancelière allemand qui va bientôt
quitter le pouvoir s'est entretenu avec
le nouveau premier ministre nathalie
bennett qui l'a qualifiée le site de
véritable ami d'israël et cela malgré
les divergences notamment sur la relance
de l'accord sur le nucléaire avec l'iran
il s'agirait d'une offensive massive
dans la région damas voisine du tigré
dissidents les forces gouvernementales
appuyées par des milices régionales y
mènent des opérations terrestres et
aériennes contre les troupes le conflit
dans le nord du pays dure maintenant
depuis 11 mois la communauté
internationale s'inquiète des
conséquences humanitaires
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france en irak elle
les premiers résultats des législatives
anticipées devraient tomber dans les 24
heures selon la commission électorale
les bureaux de vote ont fermé leurs
portes à une participation timide
quelques soucis techniques le taux de
participation est attendue ce soir il
était de 30% dans l'après-midi les
électeurs étaient appelés à choisir 329
députés un scrutin loin de passionner
les jeunes fatigué de la corruption voit
cela avec sandra tian bo
plus de deux cent cinquante mille agents
de sécurité déployées à l'entrée des
bureaux de vote en irak en ce jour
d'élections législatives dans ce pays où
le groupe etat islamique reste actif les
aéroports et les lieux de loisirs fermés
rouvriront lundi matin les déplacements
entre provinces sont également proscrits
dans le centre de bagdad rares sont les
électeurs à avoir fait le déplacement
dès l'aube mais les premiers votants ont
souligné l'importance de ce scrutin
balala
nous espérons que les gens éliront de
nouvelles personnes qui les servira les
aiderons et réaliseront leurs souhaits
tout le monde va venir voter il est
inacceptable que les gens restent chez
eux s'ils ne participent pas aux
élections les mêmes visages restaurant
la crise dans le pays persistera il n'y
aura aucun progrès
la raison pour laquelle je vote et pour
remplacer la classe dirigeante par une
nouvelle génération qui pourra
comprendre la souffrance du peuple
irakien qui atteindre le niveau des pays
avancés le véritable processus
démocratique oui quand le peuple choisit
les dirigeants politiques
initialement prévue en 2022 les
élections législatives ont été avancées
pour calmer la contestation de l'automne
2010 9 alors que les autorités ont lancé
des appels aux 25 millions d'électeurs
la participation s'établissait à
seulement 30 % à la mi-journée
c'est un droit national une opportunité
pour l'irak d'avancer vers des réformes
et de répondre aux attentes des irakiens
une vie libre et descentes nous espérons
que chaque citoyen exercera son droit
constitutionnel qui est de contribuer à
tracer l'avenir de son pays et avec la
volonté de dieu nous arriverons à une
situation qui convienne aux irakiens et
au pays assez de disputes concentrons
nous sur ce qui est le plus important
la construction de l'irak et le respect
des droits des citoyens
aujourd'hui c'est la journée des
citoyens
moi du côté de l'opposition le courant
sadriste est donné grand favori
son leader bogota d'al sadr compte déjà
le plus gros bloc du parlement sortant
mais en cas de victoire il devra
composer avec les grands rivaux premier
rang et le mouvement chiite du cheikh
qais al-khazali
notre message au peuple irakien et
qu'ils participent massivement aux
élections pour le bien de son pays et de
son avenir afin que personne ne puisse
exploiter son absence
des dizaines d'observateurs
internationaux dépêchés par l'onu et
l'union européenne supervise le
processus un scrutin toutefois boycotté
par les militants de la contestation qui
décrivent cette élection comme
antidémocratique
les résultats des élections irakiennes
sont connus et c'est un jeu où la classe
politique se relaient et se
redistribuent les ministères cela
concerne aussi le poste de premier
ministre la présidence du parlement
ainsi que la présidence c'est clair
tous les quatre ans il tourne
les premiers résultats sont attendus
dans les 24 heures après la fermeture
des bureaux de vote quant au verdict
définitif du scrutin il sera rendu dans
une dizaine de jours selon la commission
électorale
et écoutez l'analyse de yun fbl fellah
et les consultants en relations
internationales spécialiste du monde
arabe il détaille les changements
attendus par la population
d'abord la lutte contre la corruption
parce qu'il faut rappeler quand même que
l'irak a convenu comme m des vagues de
corruption très intéressante on parle
quand même de 2000 milliards de dollars
de dépenses et de vols qui ont été volés
dans ce pays pendant les dix dernières
li dernières années deuxièmement la
question économico sociale qui est ligne
et à
allah le pouvoir d'achat et la question
du chômage et troisièmement à l'enjeu
que je trouve très intéressant pour ce
pays c'est la question aussi de la
sécurité il faut rappeler que toutes les
organisations terroristes est
principalement l'état islamique a trouvé
un terrain de jeu très intéressant en
irak et la même crié à certains moments
des des émirats on va dire islamiste
dans le pays surtout dans la partie du
mot sol et donc ce qui a fait en quelque
sorte le besoin pour l'irak d'appeler
des forces internationales d'intervenir
dans ce cadre donc là maintenant on va
dire le risque de terrorisme il est
toujours
omniprésent vu ce qui se passe tout
simplement en afghanistan pour bien
comprendre que cette région il est
toujours aux prières de nouveaux
terroristes
décidément le liban n'est pas épargnée
déjà touché par une grave crise
économique le pays a été plongé dans le
noir et hier soir le courant il est
revenu aujourd'hui
en cause l'arrêt forcé des deux
principales centrales électriques en
raison du manque de carburant pour les
alimenter en électricité du pays est
produite en grande partie par des
centrales thermiques au fioul ce type de
black-out arrive souvent pour des
raisons de rationnement de courant
écoutez à ce propos michel fayyad il est
analyste politique et financier
les répercussions sont terribles parce
que jusqu'à présent en fait lorsque
l'électricité de l'état ne fonctionnait
pas l'heure les gens vivaient grâce aux
générateurs mais les générateurs sont
fournis par des privés qui sont qui sont
organisées telles une mafia c'est pour
ça que les libanais l'appelle la mafia
des générateurs mais ces gens là en fait
s'approvisionnait grâce à des livraisons
grâce aux grâce au camion est en fête
avec la pénurie de carburant est bien
même les générateurs privés ne peuvent
plus fournir de l'électricité aux
libanais et vous savez très bien que
l'électricité c'est le coeur même de
l'économie de pour l'activité il ya un
vrai problème de fond est aujourd'hui en
fait hier et des manifestations qui ont
eu lieu contre le gouvernement parce que
ce gouvernement qui a été mise en place
après treize mois d'attentes est un
gouvernement que les libanais appelle le
gouvernement des banques donc le
gouvernement des banques par les banques
pour les banques avec un premier
ministre qui est lui même banquier
l'homme le plus riche du liban avec son
frère le ministre des finances qui est
qui qui travaillait jusque-là la banque
centrale
donc en fait voilà c'est aujourd'hui ça
que ce sur quoi les libanais assiste
au moyen orient
dernière visite officielle dans gala
merkel en israël ce dimanche pour son
huitième déplacement dans l'état hébreu
la chancelière allemande a rappelé les
liens qui unissent les deux pays une
entente cordiale mais qui ne cache pas
certains points de désaccord et angoisse
là avec théo qu'on
proximité affichée entre angela merkel
il lève talibés net pour sa huitième et
dernière visite officielle dans l'état
hébreu la chancelière allemande a
réaffirmé son amitié avec israël depuis
16 ans elle a notamment fait du droit de
tel aviv à se défendre face à ses
ennemis l'une des priorités de la
politique étrangère de l'allemagne mais
cette apparente union cache néanmoins
des points de désaccord en premier lieu
sur la question iranienne où la position
d'israël reste intransigeante
la responsabilité d'israël et d'assurer
par des actions et non par des discours
que l'iran ne disposera jamais d'armes
nucléaires des armes nucléaires entre
les mains d'un tel régime extrémiste et
violent changeront négativement le
visage de la région et du monde chanel
pour nous il ne s'agit pas d'un problème
stratégique mais une question
existentielle
ongs et la merkel de son côté défend
l'accord de vienne sur le nucléaire dont
l'allemagne il signataires elle prône la
continuité du dialogue avec l'iran
malgré les difficultés
je n'ai jamais considéré que l'accord de
vienne sur le nucléaire iranien et est
idéal mais c'est mieux que de ne pas
avoir d'accord cela peut également être
vue d'une manière différente nous nous
trouvons maintenant dans une situation
très difficile car la nouvelle
administration américaine a promis un
retour dans l'accord mais les jours
passent et l'iran ne fait aucun effort
pour une reprise des négociations
autre point de désaccord
la palestine aucune avancée notable bien
au contraire n'a été observé sur le
dossier de la création d'un état
palestinien
pendant les 16 ans de mandature qu'a
connue angela merkel la dirigeant de 67
ans reste néanmoins attaché à une
solution à deux états une hypothèse que
refuse toujours l'état hébreu
qui a
personnellement sur ce point je pense
que même si à ce stade cela semble
quasiment sans espoir l'idée d'une
solution à deux états ne doit pas être
retirée de la table elle ne doit pas
être enterrée mais nous devons aussi
toujours avoir à l'esprit comment les
palestiniens devraient pouvoir vivre en
sécurité dans un état mais le point
central est la vision dans l'état
d'israël sur juif et démocratique
nous n'ignorons pas les palestiniens ce
sont nos voisins mais ils ne vont nulle
part nous non plus
mais en même temps l'expérience nous a
appris que la création d'un état
palestinien signifierait très
probablement un état terroriste serait
établi à environ sept minutes de mon
domicile et presque partout en israël
beaucoup de dignité seul signe que la
question d'un état palestinien n'est
plus vraiment à l'ordre du jour la
chancelière allemande a décidé de ne pas
rendre visite au président de l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas
angela merkel ne devrait pas non plus
rencontré le leader de l'opposition
benyamin nétanyahou qui fut pourtant son
homologue pendant près de 12 ans en
pologne une grande mobilisation à
varsovie ce dimanche des pro européens
réunis pour écouter un lieu secours du
chef de l'opposition et l'ancien
président du conseil européen donald
tusk des polonais fier de faire partie
de l'union européenne alors que leur
pays connaît des tensions avec bruxelles
à la semaine dernière la cour
constitutionnelle a proclamé à la
primauté du droit polonais sur les lois
européennes
en ethiopie maintenant les forces
gouvernementales même tu une vaste
offensive contre les rebelles dans la
région d'amhara voisine du tigré
dissidents le conflit dans le nord du
pays dure depuis 11 mois de son côté l
onu alerte sur la situation humanitaire
en voit cela avec françois qu'est ce qui
évite ch
il ne reste plus rien de cette ferme
d'un petit village d'une vallée de la
région de la mara en août dernier une
junte militaire a attaqué les habitants
sign comme j'ai vu la junte et je me
suis enfui depuis la montagne j'ai vu
qu'il brûlait ma maison des enfants ont
été tués d'autres ont été sauvées et
j'ai ramené des survivants
tabak c'est vraiment dur vraiment dur
c'est trop vraiment trop
les villageois accusent les rebelles du
front de libération du peuple du tigré
en conflit avec les forces
gouvernementales éthiopienne des
accusations réfutées par les rebelles
qui affirment qu'il n'attaquait pas les
civils sans réelle protection de la part
des forces gouvernementales
certains villageois ont décidé dé créer
leurs propres milices
les tablettes des menaces alors non on
nous tue ce n'est pas parce que nous
soutenons un parti c'est une question de
vie ou de mort pour nous nos femmes sont
violées ou bien son pied nous sommes en
train d'être assassiné
ce vendredi les forces gouvernementales
et leurs alliés ont annoncé avoir engagé
des offensive aérienne et terrestre
contre les rebelles qui gré un présent
dans la région débuté en novembre 2020
le conflit s'est d'abord concentrée dans
le tigré où les autorités locales sont
accusés par addis abeba d'avoir
orchestré des attaques contre des camps
militaires fédéraux au fil des semaines
les combats se sont étendus aux régions
voisines de l'amfar et de la mara depuis
plusieurs mois les nations unies tirent
la sonnette d'alarmé accusant le
gouvernement d' abbey ahmed d'imposer je
cite un blocus de facto de l'aide
alimentaire
selon l'onu quatre cent mille personnes
ont franchi le seuil de la famine dans
le pays et ailleurs et je demande
instamment au gouvernement d'autoriser
l'accès sans entrave de la nourriture de
l'argent des équipements de
communication et des fournitures
humanitaires dans toutes les régions qui
en ont besoin et j'appelle tous les
membres du conseil de sécurité à faire
tout ce qui est en leur pouvoir pour
soutenir ses appels et à s'unir derrière
les efforts des nations unies et de
leurs partenaires en ethiopie la semaine
dernière sept responsables d' agences
onusiennes ont été expulsés par le
gouvernement éthiopien pour ingérence
dans les affaires du pays une décision
forte qui a suscité de sévères critiques
notamment de la part des états unis et
de la france des critiques loin
d'inquiéter le premier ministre
éthiopien il y a quelques jours habib
ahmed investi pour un nouveau mandat de
cinq ans a promis de ne pas plier face à
la pression internationale
la boîte de haut niveau
et écoutez l'analyse de patrick ferrasse
et le président c'est chez stratégie
africaine dr en géopolitique spécialiste
de la corne de l'afrique
pour pas trop à une humiliation
quelconque l'identique n envoyer un
envoyé spécial les etats unis aussi à
ben yahmed est persuadé qu'il a raison
que c'est apprendre une souveraineté
intérieur donc il ne discutera qu'à
partir du moment où peut-être il y aura
une grande victoire sur le terrain ce
qui est entendu ce qui est en train de
se passer pour lui après avoir été nommé
premier ministre pour cinq ans ils
voient une victoire militaire de manière
à mettre la région du tigré opa si l'on
peut dire donc l'enjeu de ce code de ce
conflit qui vient de redémarrer dans sa
troisième étape si l'on peut dire c'est
que habib ahmed va chercher une victoire
écrasante sur le type i l est pour
l'instant sous les il ya eu énormément
de mobilisation on parle de 400 500
mille personnes sous les armes si l'on
peut dire et donc les premières victimes
vont être sept ces combats qui va être
féroce entre les tigres et un de côté et
l'armée fédérale aidés par les milices
direction taïwan le pays ne cédera pas
aux pressions chinoises la présidente de
l'île située à quelques kilomètres de la
chine a refusé l'idée de réunification
avec un son voisin elle s'est exprimée
alors de la charte nationale les détails
avec michael dos santos était aux
comptes
malgré l'ambiance de fête nationale la
présidente taïwanaise n'a pas tourné en
rond lors de son discours taïwan a une
nouvelle fois campé sur ses positions et
a réaffirmé sa volonté de défendre
l'indépendance de son territoire et ce
malgré les récentes menaces chinoises
aux mêmes pourrait marquer ils n'agiront
pas de manière irréfléchie mais il ne
faut absolument pas imaginer que le
peuple taiwanais cède aux pressions nous
continuerons à renforcer notre défense
nationale et à démontrer notre
détermination à nous défendre afin de
garantir que personne ne puisse forcer
taiwan emprunter la voie que la chine a
tracé pour nous en effet la voie tracée
par la chine offre au ni ni un mode de
vie libre et démocratique à taïwan ni la
souveraineté à nos 23 millions
d'habitants au pinceau comme
la veille devant plusieurs centaines
d'invités le président chinois chint
qingping commémorait le 110e
anniversaire de la révolution de 1911
qui renversa la dernière dynastie
impériale celle des kings une cérémonie
dont le leader communiste s'est servi
pour rappeler sa volonté d'unir taiwan à
la chine continentale
il re ping pong cheviet réaliser la
réunification de la patrie par des
moyens pacifiques et dans l'intérêt
général de la nation chinoise y compris
des compatriotes de taiwan
[Musique]
ce qu'ils oublient leurs ancêtres
trahissent la mère patrie et divise le
pays ne finissent jamais bien ils seront
rejetés par le peuple est jugée par
l'histoire
séparés par un détroit la chine
continentale et l'île de taïwan sont
divisés depuis 1949 et la victoire du
parti communiste sur les forces
nationalistes de tchang kaï-chek ces
derniers mois pékin multiplie les
incursions dans l'espace aérien
taïwanais les dernières datant de la
semaine passée pour la seule journée du
4 octobre près de 56 avions chinois ont
été repérés dans le ciel de taïwan
soutenu par les états unis le
gouvernement taïwanais ne craint plus de
montrer sa résolution à recourir à la
force si nécessaire une ligne rouge pour
ching trang ping qui a fait du concept
de chine unique un des piliers de la
diplomatie chinoise une situation qui
semble inextricable alors que les
visites de responsables occidentaux se
multiplient sur l'île provoquant la
colère rouge de pékin
et le rasta de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images
cette manifestation en belgique à
bruxelles plus de 80 mg on défilait
alors d'une grande mobilisation contre
le climat un cortège qui a rassemblé
plus de 25 mille personnes selon la
police à trois semaines de la coop 26 à
glasgow les protestataires réclament des
mesures supplémentaires afin de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
un attentat à la voiture piégée au yémen
aden dans le sud du pays selon un bilan
provisoire six personnes sont mortes 11
sont sortis ont été blessés un convoi
officiel était visé le gouverneur d'aden
et le ministre de l'agriculture ont péri
dans cette attaque une enquête a été
ouverte par le gouvernement d'union
l'attentât il n'a pas été revendiquée
pour le moment
et puis cette tragique incident d'avion
dans le centre de la russie c'était ce
matin seize personnes sont mortes dans
ce crash une annonce du ministère des
situations d'urgence via le réseau
social télégramme six personnes ont pu
être secourues l appareil s'est écrasé à
9h23 exactement heure française dans la
république du tatarstan non loin de la
ville de kazan un problème de
défaillance moteur fret à l'origine du
drame selon les autorités locales
en france le mouvement saccage paris se
fait entendre les étaient plusieurs
centaines à manifester ce dimanche dans
les rues de la capitale à six mois de la
présidentielle elle dénonce le confort
de vie en baisse la propreté de la ville
ou encore les difficultés de circulation
un mécontentement appuyé par une étude
de l'ifop qui déclare que huit parisiens
sur 10 ouf que la capitale est sale
on voit bien que les gens peuvent plus
circuler on va bien qu' il ya des des
vraiment d'aider des boues endroits
historiques qui sont là aujourd'hui on
parle de la reconfiguration du parvis de
notre-dame de la reconfiguration de la
place de la concorde des champs-elysées
de temps ma question est la seule
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui quand même
la ville de paris 1 dt le 11 mai 2009 1
la mairie de paris avait décidé de
fermer la rue de rivoli qu'on veut que
les grands axes comme la rue de rivoli
le couloir sébastopol le bois aux
marchés restent accessibles on peut
étudier effectivement des zones attrapé
limitée dans des petits quartiers mais
on peut pas bloquer tout le centre de
paris pour en faire un nouveau ghetto
pour jeunes riches en bonne santé quand
vous touchez à la ville vous touchez à
nos vies vous touchez au commerce et si
vous touchez à de commerce il va pas
nous indemniser sinon on va devoir faire
baisser de rideau cette passe d'armes
maintenant entre gérald darmanin et
grégory douce et le ministre de
l'intérieur était ce jeudi en
déplacement dans le rhône à cette
occasion il a critiqué la politique
sécuritaire de lyon plus petits skis
spécifiquement de son maire écologiste
pas assez de caméras de
vidéosurveillance dans la capitale des
gaules selon le premier flic de france
l'édile a n'a pas apprécié lui si on
voit cela avec guillemard osé
ici à lyon des caméras de
vidéosurveillance on peut en voir et
bien un peu partout la ville a même été
l'une des pionnières en la matière c'est
le maire et ex premier ministre raymond
barre qui a réalisé les premiers
investissements à la fin des années 90
notamment ici sur la presqu'île dans le
centre ville alors depuis le dispositif
s'est bien étoffé mais il reste toujours
insuffisant selon gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur était en visite
dans le département il y a quelques
jours et il n'a pas mâché ses mots
écoutez nous devons faire beaucoup mieux
sur le nombre de caméras de
vidéoprotection à lyon je recommande aux
maires dont c'est la compétence d'aller
vers cela l'état fait sa part et est
prêt à financer une partie de ses
installations alors sans surprise cette
critique elle n'a pas été du tout du
goût du maire écologiste grégory doucet
qui a répliqué dans la journée la
présence de la vidéo protection est
assurée là où elle doit l'être nous
avons 571 caméras dans la ville nous
sommes l'une des villes en france les
mieux équipées et c'est vrai en valeur
absolue lyon occupe une place honorable
parmi les communes les mieux dotés
encore faut-il rapporté ce chiffre à la
population hélas la capitale des gaules
se retrouve à la traîne de nom onze
villes de france avec une caméra pour
près de 900 habitants c'est lui fois
moins qu'à nice la championne de la
catégorie un retard qui inquiète - le
maire écologiste que le nombre de
policiers dans sa ville
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ce ne sont
pas les caméras qui permet d'attraper
les délinquants l'enjeu c'est une
présence humaine avec des effectifs
renforcés
l'efficacité de la vidéosurveillance une
question souvent posée et qui peine à
trouver une réponse définitive
les quelques études réalisées pointerait
tout de même vers une absence de lien
entre le nombre de caméras et le niveau
d'insécurité
la france se caractérise par la quasi
absence d' enquêtes scientifiques sur
l'efficacité de la vidéosurveillance
les études menées à l'étranger ne
permettent pas globalement de conclure à
l'efficacité de la vidéosurveillance de
la voie publique aucune corrélation
global n'a été relevé entre l'existence
de dispositifs de vidéoprotection et le
niveau de la délinquance commise sur la
voie publique alors la vidéosurveillance
utile ou pas ce qui est sûr c'est que le
sujet est sensible et c'est un marqueur
politique les édiles de droite y ont
davantage recours que ceux à gauche en
tout cas selon les quelques chiffres
existants ce qui est sûr c'est que ces
oppositions ne manqueront pas de se
faire sentir durant la campagne
présidentielle où le thème de la
sécurité est déjà omniprésent et on va
s'intéresser maintenant à cette enquête
une étude de la prestigieuse revue
scientifique the lancet qui concerne
l'impact du commis de 19 sur la santé
mentale des personnes les chiffres
prouvant que la pandémie a fait bondir
les cas de dépression et d'anxiété à ce
dimanche marque justement la journée
mondiale de la santé un mental plus de
détails en images
bon
on
pour le pr
cela souligne un besoin urgent de
renforcer les systèmes de santé même
avant la pandémie les systèmes de soins
de santé mentale de la plupart des pays
manquait de ressources et étaient
désorganisés répondre à cette demande
supplémentaire sera difficile mais il
n'est pas envisageable de ne rien faire
[Musique]
on
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans une trentaine de minutes rester
avec nous frères défense
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres et le silence qui parle
[Musique]
en afghanistan le passage du pouvoir aux
talibans après vingt ans de guerre est
une défaite pour l'ensemble des
occidentaux en tant que membre de l'otan
un pays comme la france peut se poser
des questions sur la vision américaine
de l'organisation et la prise de
contrôle du marché des sous marins
australiens par les états unis montrent
qu'une alliance entre anglo saxons pour
faire face à la chine est en train de se
construire c'est un signe manifeste
d'une longue dégringolade de notre
posture à la fois stratégiques
politiques sur la scène internationale
et industriels aussi les pays européens
sont ils perçus comme des pourvoyeurs de
troupes de supply